قالت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان الانسحاب
مستمر من المنطقه الشماليه وان هناك هبوطا
في حجم القتال وسيتم تسريح مزيد من القوات
في الايام القادمه واضافت وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه ان الفرقه
ال8 تقود سبعه الويه في محور خانيونس بهدف
تحديد مكان الاسرى وتصفيه قياده حماس
وتدمير البنيه التحتيه العسكريه كما ان
التغييرات في طبي القتال حسب وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه تحدث رغم رفض نتنياهو
الحديث عن اليوم التالي لاسباب سياسيه حسب
زعمه وقالت وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه ان
الجيش معني بالانتقال الى المرحله التاليه
الاكثر دقه والتي تقوم على سحب قوات الجيش
من داخل القطاع والتحرك المستقبلي بها من
داخل الاراضي الاسرائيليه نحو الاهداف
وليس من داخل القطاع وذلك حتى تصبح هدفا
للخلايا المسلحه حسب
تعبيرها